bonjour super de retrouver ces vies car
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur for honor
non pas le jeu qui sort le 14 février
mais sur la bêta ouverte qui est a lieu
bah ça ferme en une heure c'est une
blague que mika apprécié et l'a vraiment
rigoler dans la méthode le 3 juin tout
comme ça avec les cas on avait envie de
mettre des coups tp dans des genres il
ya trois classes ya vikkings je sais
plus samouraïs et non d'après samouraï
parce qu'on a un petit côté japonais et
konichiwa moi c'est parce que j'aime
bien kebab ça serait ok ce parti mais
qu'on va jouer un dominion et avec mika
on s'est dit on va faire les [ __ ] on va
camper sur un point on va vraiment
camper un point et des canadiens ont
fait une embuscade ça te plaît me
cascade ouais ok mais casser parti tim
samouraï vasisht assumer car je te vois
oh lala com train de te battre et les
sous marques
ils sont la face au chanteur mika
sociaux il a pu de vie pas encore
attends tu dis où tu t'en fous tu t'en
fous et hop là au blabla je les chasse
et on dépense des fonds sont des faux
pas il te suffit que tu me reconnais
c'est moi qui ai ne cambriole en salle
sur la tête moi j'ai une kippa sur la
tête
jamais en paix car attention il n'a pas
aimé c'est un raciste il antisémite
s'agit l'attaqué parle aux attaques par
le ou les tiens on la démolit yamano ok
magazine
je n'attaque pas le haut débit car je
suis au chômage depuis berlin vient là
bien il va se tourner fait guère plus à
faire mal vas-y je prends l'autre moi ok
c'est bon j'en ai eu un thème en eau et
a démonté et jeté venger olala mondiaux
mais quel combat
à comment chaque branche vas-y vas-y
vas-y oui on y en a qui remet bien mais
qu il fait le malin et rétro le fier il
fait trop le fier aux [ __ ] à te
casses toi ok c'est bon j'ai j'habite à
aa qui peut tester les samouraïs
j'aime ouais moi aussi moi aussi je peux
encore rien atteint genre j'appelle les
archers à merde c'est pas ça godet à
tanger avec jacques et son dos et son
dos un [ __ ] tu en viens gagner à moi
ils sont morts ils sont venus à 3 des
cas tiens c'est prendre en sandwich rica
hockey chez en mode vengeance je suis
hyper manière jean hameau de vengeance
mon gars j'en ai eu un bon j'en ai eu le
moa doit réellement lève mon nom mais
shanghai chine - un homme était qu un
mika on va retourner sur cette zone
on va prendre ce qui nous revient de
droit aux là on prend les chaînes on
prend les chaînes la discrétion c'est
avant tout pour d'une échelle est arrivé
face à l'ennemi mais c'est un peu notre
terre on est l'un des présents aux
adaptations à face aux dépenses on
dépose le texte une balle de ping-pong
tuer leurs héros oh [ __ ] vallée
démolir bien là michaël youn à la tiens
tiens ok il y en a un qui est mort le
deuxième il est là il est hyper v ner je
tiens tiens c'est gagné attends je te
reste j'étais vraiment bien là il ya des
pions qui m'attaquent c'est bon mais moi
je m'en vais en bataille l'attend le mec
qui les attendent les chez alcoa hier le
bien des achats trolard vacciner chez
elle alors tu veux ma peau d'un vase été
postées aux défauts sont des faux tiens
campeurs ça t'apprendra à camper petit
temps qu'il est bravo je suis premier ça
parfois de la ville ça m'arrive asie
partie suivante c'est parti on est chaud
ah non on avec deux bottes et en fait
ces quatre vrais mecs mais elle a
annoncé ce parti vas-y on va tout droit
en masse par an on va tout droit dans la
mêlée mais bon on va se faire démolir
attends je me cachais la attire les je
me cachais derrière le mur ici ok je le
vois hélas embuscade
oh [ __ ] j'ai moins ils sont beaux ils
sont tous les sondages ils sont dehors
je voulais de courir mon gars ont démoli
à y en a quelques micarna qui me suit
thomas qui est reçu à temps je vais
faire une embuscade tout ça ça
t'apprendra à me suis fais aux [ __ ]
il me suivait mec je lui ai tendu une
embuscade aux [ __ ] qu'arrive obtint à
2 ans 1 2 milliard je me bats hop dayz a
révisé en baisse à un milliard est tout
à fait mais quatre ou alors [ __ ] à
part de ma mine giffard dont bas de
tableau halo reach hâter la fin
bazire événements merci aussi qu'elle
nous réveille
bah oui tu breakdance au sol va pas se
mentir il est mort à l'issue morsures
sur rien à ses moyens sur moi à tanger
un petit pouvoir auquel je récupère ma
vie j'y arrive mais 4 mai cap toi haché
marché marc ils sont tous sur moi je
suis mort hi-media faut qu'on se
regroupe faut qu'on fasse un rush sur à
bien ont fait le tour on va reprendre a
atteint cheval c'est pas un mec derrière
non c'est bon on n'est pas suivi on va
prendre à et dès qu'un mec qui vient au
line up est le best buds l'embuscade
embuscade bonus à berck les bars et les
voir c'est bon c'est bon c'est juste un
truc mais qu'as tu te fais taper touche
pas avec autant sur moi j'ai les armes
avec un michael radio me tiens ils sont
trois ils sont trois c'était un viol
alors on n'était pas loin d'y aller pour
mais tim k de bottes
moi je me rassure comme je pose mes cas
je te prends un verre d'homme à homme
c'est moi qui prends nommé me lis pas
dans ma communauté s'il te plaît moi
j'ai trop peur allez vas-y bien c'est
pas une technique pour de vrai nom tu
regarderas pas les coups spéciaux mika
mais non mais je me souviens que kim
dong ho [ __ ] [ __ ] et
oui permet tent hagen dame a bien bien
bas nomades sommes bien madame madame
madame matmata j'ai vu un truc là-bas
mais les pitchouns aller j'ai contribué
j'avais un bel geddes au [ __ ] j'ai
battu 1000 kg battu michael est allé kim
a gagné on s'est demandé ce que ça va
être serré
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] au nom laissant prévoir un tel
duel bien joué et bien joué un partout
partout attention ces trois manches
gagnantes a bien tenté d'attenter aux
[ __ ] huawei ren m'attaquer cela au
nom non mais bon perso quand il est bas
vie mais qui devient nul ouais je parle
plus français des basques
allez allez allez fogel ça va me cadeau
j'ai fait exprès allez c'est la belle
c'est la grande finale c'est ce que
voulait voir dans cette vidéo du beau
jeu oui
on sait tout ça peut s'expliquer bâtarde
quoi le doute s'est amusé à lescure et
fois turquie les excuses mais tu veux
pas juste dire bravo [ __ ] t'es trop
fort non match des prochaines et elle
voilà les amis dit attentif n'hésitez
pas à aller mais ça vous a plu merci
week-end avoir rejoint et d'avoir perdu
comme une énorme merde faire esprit
n'hésitez pas à passer par lâcher de
mecha junas ou d'approché 200 regarder
portez vous bien sûr du monde
ça